all right got my PlayStation Vita and
what better game to review than a game
that's like the staple PlayStation 3
franchise
no no not you crash No
uncharted golden Abyss alright so
initial reviews that I saw said that
uncharted golden abyss was kind of like
uncharted light and I just didn't want
that I'm gonna play Uncharted I want an
uncharted game but I figured it is
Uncharted I do have a PlayStation Vita
so I'm gonna get it anyway come to find
out the game actually really impressed
me first so first of all uncharted
golden Abyss is not made by naughty dog
studios the studio that makes all the
other Uncharted games it's made by bends
studios so I figured oh if there's any
possibility this is going to be
uncharted light it's not because it's on
the PlayStation Vita it's because of
completely different companies making it
although I guess Naughty Dog did oversee
the production but just saying they
actually do a really good job this game
feels like a legit uncharted game to the
point where even the dialogue is perfect
I actually had to check IMDB to see if
the game was written and directed by Amy
Hennig who does the other Uncharted
games turns out it's not it's written
and directed by someone completely
different but you would not know it if
this is what an imitation uncharted game
looks and feels like well then I'm
perfectly fine with it so other than
being a really legit Uncharted game how
does it incorporate some of the PS
Vita's features it has to feel gimmicks
in it some I like some I did not like
we'll start with the ones I didn't like
because I just like good news being last
the dumbest Dimmick in the game is when
you're fighting someone you'll see this
little arrow go across the screen you
have to swipe the screen in that
direction why do you have to do that I
have no idea but you do and it felt like
you were playing touch screen Dragon's
Lair at that point it really rubbed me
the wrong way where the entire last
fight of the game is all that you're
just swiping the screen in whatever
direction it tells you to do it and
that's how you fight the boss after
you're done boss is dead game is over I
didn't like that I'd rather have a fight
ultimately in terms of the gimmicks in
the game it's the one I really didn't
like some of the gimmicks I did like I
saw that when you're climbing a wall or
something you can just take your finger
and run across the path that you want
them to go and he'll do that which
officially saves you energy how much
energy this much energy how lazy am I to
think that that's actually a good
feature but I liked it and the
touchscreen makes it feel like you're
actually doing some archaeology work
you'll find these imprints you have to
do a choc rub you know you just rub the
screen like this it makes you do a choc
rubbing coolest gimmick in the entire
game is where you get this blank piece
of paper and someone was like oh hold it
up to a light source maybe you'll be
able to see a message but the screen is
just a piece of paper
sure like I don't I looked up at my
light and I was like no way and it held
my PSVita up to my light you see the
message shine right through the piece of
paper in terms of gimmick that is one of
the coolest gimmicks a game has ever
done some was like the games like I'm
now you know we can do that we'll never
do it again in the entire game but now
you know but I really like that some of
the game kind of feels like a bit of a
back slide after uncharted 2 and 3 now
uncharted 2 & 3 had a lot of playable
cutscenes like you're in a building that
is collapsing and you're still fighting
guys and furnitures just flying against
the wall moments like that aren't really
in this game although uncharted golden
Abyss does do a good job at making it
feel intense you know when stuff's
blowing up around you but not like that
I would actually put the quality of this
game up there with uncharted 1 it is not
worse than uncharted 1 so for nothing
else it's as good as uncharted drake's
fortune not as good as uncharted 2 among
thieves and uncharted 3 drake's
Deception but it is still a quality game
and a really legit uncharted game
there's just no way that that's bad no
universe whatsoever the dialogues
perfect Nathan Drake still feels like
Nathan Drake it plays like a console
game and that's what I really like
because this is how I see it you know
how like games will have a franchise and
they'll make a chapter on that franchise
for a portable game system and it just
plays different all you want is a game
on a portable game system that plays
like your console version of that game
franchise even Metal Gear Solid portable
ops it has weird mechanics for your like
Metal Gear Solid on the consoles just
play differently than the portable
versions Uncharted golden Abyss plays
like a console version of Uncharted just
in your hand everything flowed that's
all I wanted I will say it this way
uncharted golden Abyss is the best
launch title for a portable system since
the original Tetris for the original
Gameboy yeah that's like that it's good
so do you have a PS Vita yet have you
played Uncharted golden Abyss if not
what's your favorite Uncharted game
whatever it is comment below let me know
and as always if you like what you've
seen here and you want to see more click
right here to see more I'm gonna go play
Mass Effect 3 that'll take a while to be
so be patient